as the finale to the wolf among us can't
shave for the finale to the wolf among
us good wolf among us finale I guess I
want to talk about some spoilers in the
wolf among us episode 5 short answers
yeah buy it play it right now I'm going
to talk about some spoilers for Episode
five yeah I didn't review the wolf among
this episode for everything I enjoyed
about the previous episodes I just
hadn't played it this ultimately comes
down to that hole waiting for every
episode business model I'll get to that
a little later but for now just know
that you find the main dick that is
running everything who looks and sounds
a lot like Max von Sydow so I'm gonna
call him max von see down now I gotta
lie though in episode 4 when I came on
that guy and he was like please sit down
you have a few choices one was to light
your cigarette I was like egg has just
seen the coolest thing to do when it's
max von sydow gets away with Bloody Mary
and you fight a few guys actually a
pretty intense fight - there are a few
good fights in the wolf among us like
when you're fighting Bloody Mary in
episode 5 you turn into huge big be wolf
like big be true wolf is like a huge
10-foot wolf and you're biting these
glass and shattering I'm buddy
Mary is a she's she sucks great
character but sucks as a human being or
a fable
didn't you get max von C down he's like
I'm no criminal I'm I'm like let me
guess businessman businessman course you
are that's what villain dicks say so I
guess you can kill him right then in
there but I promise Snow White I gave my
word that I would let him live so I cuff
him and I bring him in and I'm glad I
did that I'd like to replay it see if I
can actually kill him right on the spot
but when you bring them in you have the
Chrono Trigger trial feel like you got
to choose your words wisely and this
guy's like out I mean max von
see how he's a pretty good wordsmith and
you can tell he is a businessman because
he can lock his case down you're like
I'm losing ground I'm losing the
crowd I had one goal and one goal only I
let him live so I wouldn't murder him
but then when we find him guilty I'm
gonna drop him down the witching wild
that's what I'm gonna do so I need this
guy to be guilty in our eyes and the
eyes are the fables around me in the end
he wasn't like Big B what would you do
and I was like holy well I mean
should I just kill him I mean I can't
rip his head off you the option is there
to rip his head off I can't do that
because that'll villainize myself drop
him down the witching well though I mean
that's not extreme is it mean I
think it's just that's how they do it in
fable town if I drop him down the
witching well then I should be fine I
imagine there's gonna be a couple people
who will be pissed but that's just our
justice is anyone going to cry for him
know that dude that lien
just kicked down the well and 300 no one
cried for that dick so no one's gonna
cry from Max von seed out here alright I
might drop him down to wish you well I
think I should I'll be safe yeah I think
that's a good thing right then in there
he grabbed me with his handcuffs he's
like guys doing his villain speak I
was just like all you tried to kill a
government official here's the way I see
it if you're innocent on all the other
were thrown at ya
you just tried to kill the sheriff and
well now you die so I spun around and I
was like oh I was gonna let you go but
now now alone and I dropped him and
killed him and I was fine with that but
I love that I love that trial I like
trials and games I just do any time a
game can feel like my actions truly are
shaping the game that was the thing
about this I was doing things throughout
all five episodes and I was like are my
actions really shaping anything by the
end when you're like oh you mean I have
to be in a good light in the eyes of the
people and not be a dick okay if you're
like in order for justice to be served I
had to have been a good person luckily I
was what I loved about the wolf among us
is it shows how diverse these telltale
games can be the wolf among us has a
completely different vibe than The
Walking Dead The Walking Dead your
feeling is you're alone but you find
family you know you find family among
some survivors so when they die it
really hurt they're like oh that
guy died like that chose to do oh my god
the wolf among us your feeling is you're
alone and you don't have that feeling of
family or connection with anybody or
nothing else you're feeling is
irritation with everybody because
everyone thinks you're a dick when
you're just trying to do a good job so
it feels less emotional although there
was a really sweet emotional moment just
dudes dying you can choose whether or
not to end his suffering about killing
him or not I was like I don't have the
heart to leave the guy to just suffer
and die so I killed him I really felt
like if I was there it would have held
the dude and be like I'm sorry I will
try to make it right although you've
been a dick for five episodes now so
well you but I'll try to make it
right but the wolf among us isn't
supposed to feel like The Walking Dead
yeah I had more of a connection with the
Walking Dead because it is more
emotional because you did have those
holy moments when people died but
the wolf among us has a really awesome
mystery investigative tone to it that
the Walking Dead doesn't have my main
gripe is that business model with the
episodes sequentially coming out when I
played the original Walking Dead by
Telltale Games I played it on marathon
day so I didn't get that episodic
feeling and this time around I was like
oh I'm going to get that episodic
feeling and that's going to be cool but
ultimately I didn't like it
like playing one episode than having to
wait two more months to play one more
episode than waiting two more - now
that's what I learned from this just
give me all five episodes right out the
gate so I can just marathon it have fun
with the game and that's yes I have not
reviewed the telltale games Walking Dead
Season 2 episode 3 I believe it is I'm
not gonna lie to you I will review
season 2 when episode 5 comes out
because I'm going to play three four and
five back-to-back and just have more fun
with it that way it looks like from now
on in the telltale games business model
I'm gonna wait until all episodes for
all the games are out and I'm just going
to play them that's how I personally
have more fun and playing each episode
just feel like I have to it's a grind
and I enjoy it less but I have to do it
to make a video about it at that point
making the video is the priority and
that's not how it should be it's not how
games should be I don't want to see
like George Lucas I don't wanna be like
I'm gonna do it for money so sense an
element of the fun was kind of taken
away because of waiting two months for
the next step is so kind of thing you
don't get the full blast of it like I
like to do in this game that is
ultimately water under the bridge
because if you're watching this review
that means all five episodes are out
right now so I'm gonna rate it like that
for 25 bucks you can go out there and
get all five episodes of the wolf among
us I think on Steam you can get it for
half that if the right sails around and
truth be told I had a blast with the
wolf among us I love Big B wolf I love
Snow White I do like their chemistry I
like the misfits that you talked to your
roommate Colin I was always cool with
him the Frog was a dick but I always
tried to help him but he's one of those
self-sabotaging deadbeat dad
and you can't save people from
themselves the wolf among us was a blast
I loved the end it really felt like all
of your decisions mattered at the very
end I can't give it the coveted awesome
tacular but I will say the wolf among us
season one as a whole is definitely
worth buying at full price at the end of
the wolf among us kind of rates what you
did compared to what other players did
totes Kidd gives you a gift to give Snow
White this is like 97% of players
accepted the gift which means she's like
3% of players out there who are dicks
who's gonna tell that kid nah keep your
gifts no White's gonna hate it guys
really he's a kid and he's going to the
farm god knows what's out there so the
wolf among us have you played it what
did you think about it but every thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more